OK, let's get into audience questions for
the week, some very good ones.
First one is about Trump voters.
Hey, David, why is it that rural and blue
collar as well as older white people seem
to favor Donald Trump?
So, yes, that is true.
It's important to remember that increasingly
this group is not leaning as much towards
Trump as they as they once were.
We looked at numbers in I believe it was Pennsylvania,
maybe Wisconsin, some other places where the
white vote is not as in favor of Donald Trump
this year as it was in 2016.
But the final numbers remain to be seen.
But, yes, it's true that Donald Trump's strongest
demographic group remains white folks and
older folks, although older folks overall
have abandoned Trump and now favor Joe Biden.
But the question is, why is a good one?
And understanding the why is necessary if
Democrats don't want to make the same mistakes
as as they did in 2016?
Now, of course, 2016 was rife with, you know,
James, his press conferences about Hillary
Clinton's emails and foreign meddling, you
know, all these different factors.
But there was a bit of a lack of understanding
from from Hillary Clinton and Democrats about
how to talk about economic anxiety.
Now, there was racism.
There's this big debate over anybody saying
economic anxiety explains Trump's win is ignoring
racism.
No, it was both.
And for some people, it was more one more,
more one or the other.
But there's no doubt that over the last 20,
30 years of globalization, as we've seen much
manufacturing go elsewhere and the U.S. become
more of a service based economy, the people
disproportionately affected by that are folks
working in manufacturing jobs.
Manufacturing jobs are disproportionately
in more rural areas and Midwestern states
and in other places like that.
And those who have benefited from the United
States moving towards being a service economy
have been people on the coasts, in cities,
tech workers, service workers and others.
So one reality is that on in total, you know,
there was this neo liberal idea that in the
aggregate, the U.S. would do better.
The economy would in total be better.
There would be more total wealth and lower
overall prices with this change of moving
manufacturing out and creating service and
information jobs that happened.
But it was overwhelmingly concentrated in
certain parts of the country and not in others.
But politics aside, it was also overwhelmingly
concentrated for the one percent as we see
stagnant wages for large swaths of Americans
and huge income and wealth gains for the top
one percent and even groups smaller than the
top one percent.
So for some people, they purt fell for Trump's
rhetoric around trade and the middle class.
It was B.S. populist rhetoric.
It went nowhere.
But there was a group already predisposed
to favor Republicans in many parts of the
country, rural, older, white, who fell for
it.
And it has not gone particularly well for
them now separately.
If you look at evangelical and religious voters,
they also are predisposed to vote on abortion
lines.
Trump claimed to be anti-abortion in 2016.
He still claims to Hillary Clinton was in
favor of a woman's right to choose.
So for some folks, it's not actually about
economics.
It's as simple as as abortion, which continues
to be a not only a voting issue, but the voting
issue for many Americans.
So there's whenever we want to look into these
questions, this is part of what I spoke about
earlier this week in our interview about the
U.S. possibly as several countries, 331 million
people.
Most countries don't have this many people.
And you have radically different not just
ideologies, but concerns.
And day to day life, the day to day life of
someone who lives in Boston and works at a
tech firm has almost nothing to do with the
life of someone who is a, you know, rural
Ohio factory worker.
We speak the same language.
We're Americans, et cetera.
But these are very live different day to day
experience, both culturally and even just
in the nuts and bolts logistics of it.
And you can't really give one answer to any
question that asks about such a broad trend
in a country of 330 million people.